à combien croyez-vous qu'il y ait de
papus ne faut trop d'écho beauté bien
sûr trois mois dans votre attention
il nous manque un
[Musique]
allez nouvelle année plus belle
mes chers amis tout est permis tout et b
non il faut je corrigeais vers les
patins plus j'en profiterai pour faire
du bruit voyons année nouvelle année
plus belle moi j'ai vu un prince
charmant s'amuser avec le bras à aa
[Musique]
oh mon dieu le gâteau échappé belle en
très bonne année monsieur bougon de
l'année de bourgaud bonne année mes
chers amis où le beau gâteau ou trouver
il m'a donné beaucoup de mal bonjour mon
nom
après le spectacle ap avons l'honneur de
vous ben vous êtes notre invité année
nouvelle année plus belle que tous vont
souhait soit exaucé
je vais vous chanter le prince charmant
j'ai eu chaud
[Musique]
la carte mère que tout
oh
au près tout
photo
c'est pour
bon
je suis
bravo maintenant les rois des claques
[Musique]
pour terminer honneur à la grâce au
charme avec pâte à tarte
[Musique]
le gâteau ce n'est pas grave moi pas
grave
un si beau gâteau c'est un faux gâteau
que j'ai fait pour pouvoir danser avec
alors ne va pas tarder à pau si le vrai
dans le four un tonneau qu'est-ce qui a
dit temps ce n'est pas vrai quand on a
au brave aubade à tarte
il est très bien imité lobby bonne année
bonne année youpi youpi
bonne année youpi youpi convient 3g vous
qu'il y ait de pata pêche il ne faut
tromper comme beauté bien sûr photo
ouattara il me manque
[Musique]